Lisa Marie Presley's ex-husband Michael
Lockwood opens up about her
incomprehensible death he can handle so
many things he cares he takes care of
everything you know I've just never seen
anyone like him in a statement to people
Michael says he and their twin daughters
Harper and Finley are reeling from the
loss of Lisa Marie adding that nothing
could have prepared them for such an
unexpected tragedy Finley's Mommy's girl
Harper's Daddy's girl Michael explains
that the most important thing at this
time is to take care of their girls as
they carry on the Family's Legacy I mean
that's what I focus on most the time
vowing to remain devoted to his
daughters I don't know what to do with
myself I'm not if I'm not a mom Lisa
Marie died January 12th after going into
full cardiac arrest her final resting
place is Graceland next to her father
Elvis and Son Benjamin it is absolutely
100 mine always has been mine Graceland
always will be the Presley family is the
state will go to Lisa Marie's three
children oldest daughter Riley Keough
and the twins and when it's no longer
mine it would be my children's you know
that's that as for who gets custody over
14 year old Harper and Finley a source
close to Michael tells E.T he obtained
full custody the moment Lisa Marie died
if something goes down Harper will want
Daddy and if something goes down with
Finley she wants meat Michael spent the
last six years battling Lisa Marie for
custody but now there's a potential new
fight Lisa Marie's first husband Danny
Keough who was living with her and the
kids at the time of her death reportedly
considers himself the girl's stepfather
he's got so much Integrity which is also
my best friend I think this is going to
end up in front of a judge if there is
going to be a dispute I don't think that
there are any concerns at this time with
his physical fitness and well-being like
there were early on in the separation in
terms of physical custody it's probably
going to go to the biological father the
twins are now 14 years old they have
minds of their own they have preferences
in terms of where they want to go to
school who they want to live with so the
court is definitely going to honor that
but for now Priscilla is doing
everything she can for her grandchildren
what do they call you Nona Nona and the
twins are currently spending all their
time with Michael and trying to keep it
as normal as possible without their
mother